that now famous engagement interview
mega mark and made it clear she was
incredibly proud of who she is and where
she came from and as we've heard since
she comes from a massive extended family
so why say for her mom and dad has she
reportedly not invited any of them to
her wedding she ashamed of them is she
trying to raise the past and people that
don't fit with her glitzy new royal life
because if the reports are true that's
what it's looking like over two and a
half thousand members of the public
strangers have been invited to the
wedding
but Megan's family apparently haven't
made the cut this despite the couple
thing they wouldn't be inviting
politicians in heads of state because
their wedding was going to be all about
family and friends just not Megan's
family I'm sorry but this is starting to
look like a statement wedding not at
home Megan is and where she came from
but who she wants to be and where she's
going the author Andrew Morton claims
that when she was a rising star Megan
just expunged people she held dear in
order to elevate her social and
professional status is that what she's
doing here expunging a family she's now
ashamed of enough reportedly and
allegedly is in their word
I think you're on an island here I think
the great British public are broadly
speaking let's say in love with a but
hugely supportive of her I think I
supported off if there's a family
wedding I don't see why the groom and or
the bride should have to invite family
that she doesn't or he doesn't really
like I think it's an extraordinary
situation that you have to have family
members that maybe you don't because I
have attended weddings and will go
around the room around the tip I have
attended weddings where family members
have not my phone but other time because
they know there's bad blood hang on we
don't even know if there is bad blood
and quite rightly and as a journalist I
knew you do that we don't yet know we
haven't yet got the official list but
this idea that Andrew Morton who again a
journalist or same sort of calibers as
ice guys expose
two people assists what we see I think
those are words that sit very very
poorly with how Britain British people
regard this woman I think it's a breath
of fresh air
let's see the list and if the girl
doesn't want Uncle Sid or whoever it is
so be it I think it's very odd in a
wedding where you have one one part of
the couple and their scores of nieces
and nephews and auntie's and uncles and
whatever and on the other side you have
mom and dad and for a while there we
didn't actually think her dad was gonna
come at one point because it because
wolves was gonna give him the potential
wedding we're never been to a wedding
where there was only two versus family
and and 580 90 of those when I heard you
were doing this topic I was so confused
because number one what business is it
of yours to be televised it is for the
nation's public are cool why why have
you got any say in who she decides to
invite to her own wedding at the end I'm
saying I think it's odd dude the two
members of our family are coming to a
wedding where there are 600 invited
guests and two and a half thousand
members of the public my point
reportedly Zelly my my my point is at
the end of the day she knows why nobody
knows you're at Sonya and I'd quite like
to know why I think she's made a huge
mistake because let me tell you why I
think she has let me explain because I
think all the family members who are
upset at not being invited
trust me some newspaper or some TV
station will bring them over here and I
think if each show might as well have
just invited and put them on a table in
a corner because her relatives are
already sick so but better to have those
people on the inside peeing out can I
say that rather than outside people you
have people okay forget let's even
forget from any other Derek they are
family if you have people in your life
that there was a time you were once
close to but you haven't seen them in
over a day that's all of her family it's
not just you
she's done amazing job she doesn't
[Laughter]
question when you were getting married
yes who did your wedding list for your
for your room guys for your guests
actually you just couldn't drop me into
there because five people at my office
then we had a big party that's what we
did yeah but you go mission care you
know you member right yeah you're
mentioning stuff like this family
members they're all being hurt and you
know there's an uncle who's apparently
really hurt that he's not yes all right
there's two mumbles yes but then the
uncle the best he can muster is going
I'm really hurt because 17 years ago I
helped Megan get a job if you release an
uncle and this and there are two
brothers the father has what is the
college you know what is it very
respected bishop the other one is the
guy you're talking about a retired US
diplomat says I think there's just
something about this this is journalism
at its worst I could go
what's worse is basically you as a
journalist trying to find a story by
finally somebody who's looking you're
saying this is out mate yeah how weird
and odd this at Madison I don't doubt
for effect for a fact she she's kind and
compassionate I say the fact she's done
incredible work to fight racism I get
all and when I Jenny ever think what I
think she but I think she also waited
look you know about the wonderful work
that she does
one day she approached me and and talked
about how as a young student she had
served on Skid Row but was very very
frightened by the experience she felt
that she had done a lot of good but she
was very very scared to go back and so
how could she asked me if I could
suggest a way that she could return to
service on Skid Row you lucky people
I've just given you an exclusive glimpse
there I don't know if you've noticed
other programs coming up handsome and
Megan or sax the love story for people
like you that are interested in it to
the rest of the world it just seems a
bit of Harry that she's not showing that
it's a crime but with the pointed that
Andrew Morton and others are making is
that on her way up to stardom Megan has
cut people out that don't fit allegedly
allegedly reportedly allegedly with her
royal life and Austin in touch with
everybody off you've stayed in touch
with everybody secretly you're upset
because you're not on the
there - no Fitzpatrick is going he's
he's on the list oh really
look we've come to the end of the show